hey guys welcome back to the second
video of today and if you haven't
watched the first video i highly
recommend you check that out it is about
the patches for the dlc or the devstream
recap of this week
this video is going to be strictly
dedicated to the new dlc characters the
shouldn't be in the centurion and only
those two
so if you guys are hyped please leave a
like on this video and let's get started
so the devs explained about the
centurions and see what's up first is
that he's going to be a very like in
your face aggressive attacker when
playing the dev said you need to be able
to dodge and get some distance to really
defeat this character he's a heavy but
kind of a slow hitter he has a lot of
damaging attacks a lot of dash forwards
and stuff like that and now he also has
a normal health pool as of a vanguard
but he's kind of a mix of like a
vanguard and like an assassin a little
bit it's kind of weird how they
mentioned it but he does have the normal
health pool of a warden or a kensei so
next up i will now show you their move
set and kind of explain what's happening
here so if no one is very and no one is
unsure of what this looks like it looks
like a bunch of jumbled up stuff because
you don't play in a certain console or
pc for the first screenshot here
the it is rb and rt for pc players that
is light attack is rb and heavy attack
is rt
and then the dash attack would be a and
then the guard break is x on the left
hand side
but for the hero specific stuff he does
have a knock back kick which is pressing
x after any throw to follow up with the
kick for an additional knock back and
stun and the imperial mite attack which
is holding the right trigger or heavy
attack to finish a chain with an
unblockable attack quick throw and kick
can be followed by imperial might which
will probably be shown later in the move
set moving on to the next picture we now
have some pc controls here so for any
console players the left mouse button
will be your
light attack the middle mouse button is
going to be your guard break and the far
right mouse button is going to be the
heavy attack the w on the screen is the
move forward obviously and the space bar
or the u shape is the dash attack
for anyone that does not know
and a little bit lower on the centurion
move list we have landing a charged
heavy attack will momentarily pin your
opponent allowing you to safely charge a
jab and the jab is the heavy attack
a little key there that is unblockable i
feel like that would probably go into
more of a a move kind of like a combo
which is why it's like a hit or release
type thing
and then eagles talon which is using
your jump attack or unboun on an
unbalanced enemies for extra damage
press the heavy mouse key near an
unbalanced enemy to trigger a jump
attack
so whenever you were to guard break
someone and throw them if you press the
heavy attack that will basically cause
you to dash forward and stab them
getting some extra distance to kind of
or getting some closer distance to close
that gap
moving on to the final picture it
doesn't really show all too much because
roman's head is kind of blocking the
perry encounter moveset
but for the ones that are showing the
lions roar attack which is a guard break
that goes into
three
a uh three light attacks the the devs
did say that this is not going to cause
any damage it's not that overpowered
you're just going to take the the butt
of your little head or the
the head of your weapon and bash their
head with it to cause them to lose
stamina so that then you can throw them
afterwards and then do your little r the
rt attack when they're down like we said
a couple seconds ago
so now that the move set is over
i will now show you their emotes and
executions for the centurion
ah
oh
[Applause]
all right guys that was really the
executions in the emotes i did enjoy the
executions for the centurion a lot i
can't wait i cannot wait to use him in
game
i do kind of like the execution where he
stabs them kind of shows off to the
crowd whips it out and cuts their head
open it's really brutal and humiliating
but now we get to move on to the shinobi
the devs explain the shinobi to be a
very fast attacker with very deadly at
long range and short range
they say that you can do a few attacks
at short range dash back to do a long
range attack and then go really quick to
kind of confuse the opponents
since he is an assassin he also has a
deflect ability but it's nothing too
overpowered basically he will kind of
teleport behind the character because i
mean come on he's a ninja he teleports
behind the person and does a quick
little jab it doesn't do a lot of damage
it only does maybe like half a bar it's
nothing too insane
but
it is very cool to witness in game
the shinobi is also both genders and has
only three bars of health making him the
weakest of characters in terms of health
he also has a super sprint ability where
he sprints faster than normal so he can
catch up to people but at the cost of
losing stamina you can revert back to
normal stamina or normal sprint speed if
you don't want to lose that stamina
now though let's get into his moveset so
first off in the first picture it seems
pretty obvious that he does have the
reflux ability seeing as he's an
assassin he can only remain in a certain
guard stance after a few amount of time
he does have a few extra combos a very
very long combo called the sickle rain
which is two heavies and then three
lights which will be a bleed damage
he has a regular
shadow dancer one which is two lights he
also has a two heavy combo and a
heavy and then a light combo he also has
a tackle ability i do they did not
actually explain what the tackle ability
is or what it looks like but i bet
that'd be super sick
moving on to the next screenshot we have
a few extra a few extra bits of
information here he has a kick ability
where it's surprise your enemy by
launching a kick which is a dash forward
i believe
if if i am not if i'm not mistaken i
believe it's a dash forward with a
ability
and then there is a bunch of you know
front rolling attacks we have some heavy
to dash into a heavy
the shinobi has probably the most
complex move set out of every character
mostly because he has the ability to
double dash forward by tapping a or the
space button whatever you happen to use
twice
then following that up with a guard
break and a heavy attack and then the
last final bit of moveset you can kind
of tell is that he has a ton of dashing
abilities that can lead into a light
attack and a heavy attack
he has a deflect which can go into a
guard break a deflect which can go into
a heavy or it's my apologies a light but
he also has a thing called shadow strike
where if he parries you and then presses
rb immediately he will do bleed damage
so try not to give yourself too much
time or try not to give himself too much
time to parry you
anyway that's going to be really of the
move set like i said he's it's the most
complex one to learn it's very difficult
to learn this character
i will know a lot more by the time the
game is out i will be showing you all of
this stuff and how to play as these
characters once they release so don't
worry about that
but for now to end the video i will just
say
to watch the new watch the emotes and
executions for the shinobi and then once
that's over that'll be the end guys so
peace out guys i will see you all next
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
oh
you